how did you like the movie Oppenheimer I
just saw it actually uh I did I did
really like it I did really enjoy it
um and I I think I'd say this to I think
I'd say this to anyone who's involved in
it I probably could have cut 40 minutes
out of that movie and I think I would
have liked it even more but I understand
and it definitely feels like a
Christopher Nolan sort of style now to
to really go into you know some of the
minutia and some into these I I didn't I
know it's based on existing material
it's based on a book haven't read the
book so I don't know how true it is to
it but uh but I liked it a lot uh I was
a little had some trepidation about
seeing it because both of my
grandfathers worked on the atomic bomb
project and because of that uh I wasn't
exactly sure exactly how I was going to
feel but uh no I thought they did a
great job did either of your
grandfathers tell you about this or
maybe you didn't interact with them or I
don't know no my my paternal grandfather
actually died when my father was 15 of
cancer and uh he was one mile from
Ground Zero at the first Trinity test so
he was there with a few other people and
uh uh was out in the desert the very
next day you know uh picking out sand
that had fused and turned into a new
material you know it's uh it it's not
surprising that he died of cancer my
maternal grandfather he died in the 70s
and I did get to meet him but I was very
young at the time I was I was still a
small child and I don't have too many
memories of my maternal grandfather he
also died of cancer so and did you have
any uh relics or you letters or things
like that yeah there's a uh there's a
letter from Oppenheimer to my uh my
paternal grandfather and it was sort of
a treasured document actually in the in
my grandmother's home growing up and so
I got to see the letter and stuff it was
a it was basically a letter of thanks
for all the contributions to the project
so did you have reservations going to
see it you said because of this or just
the timing it's a three-hour movie yeah
I I think that I had a little a little
bit of psychological trauma just you
know not really growing up with
grandfathers uh because uh be I I think
you know even though they just didn't
know very much about radiation and
radiation exposure back then and the
cumulative effects of uh radiation
poisoning back in the era of the uh
atomic bomb the atomic project the
Trinity project uh Los Alamos all of
that stuff it was uh it was very very
new and they thought they knew a lot
more about it than they did so uh I
guess I have some feelings that
ultimately that work probably led to
their deaths and so I have some some
feelings about that yeah so what can you
teach us about the cinematography of
Christopher Nolan movies oh wow that's a
great question well I think it kind of
depends on which era you're talking
about because he has very distinctive
styles that sort of span different years
talking about like you know the
following in momento it's uh it
definitely has a bit more of an indie
and gritty you know and granted some of
that has to do with resources and then
uh really really uh big shifts to slick
and glossy IMAX and really incredible uh
incredible talent that He was working
with behind the camera from probably the
eras of like you know Inception uh it
like the the budgets have just gotten so
huge he's one of the you know singular
filmmakers of uh of his generation where
he kind of gets whatever he wants
technically and can command uh can
command uh an unlimited it seemingly
amount of resources when it comes to I
know that I I know that there for a fact
that he is sometimes very specific about
cutting down some of those resources to
be able to do other things but because
he gets to start off with IMAX and he
gets to start off with a lot of the
technology that other filmmakers only
dream about um he can do amazing things
he can he can work with this canvas that
most people can't even dream of what is
documentary style lighting oh
documentary style lighting documentary
style lighting generally is not the same
as narrative lighting so when you're
talking about a narrative production
quite often lights are set up very
specifically for a shot or maybe for a
specif or an area um when you're talking
about documentary style lighting you're
usually giving all of the people who are
the subject of your documentary free
reign to move you you're not boxing them
or limiting them you're not rehearsing
blocking quite often with documentary
style lighting so it really is sort of a
fundamental shift between a very
controlled very uh aesthetic style of
narrative film making and a I want to
say I don't want to say Lucy goosey it's
not Lucy goosey but it is uh it provides
the subjects much more freedom and if
they might if they move into Shadow they
might move into shadow in narrative film
making there's it's almost always very
intentional there there's an intention
if someone Moves In the Shadow there's
an intention of someone's in the light
there's an intention if someone is you
know if there's defract light or
reflected light or anything else that's
going on so it's different with
documentary have you ever been on a
Christopher Nolan set no I've never been
on a Christopher Nolan set but um uh one
of his camera operators Michael Fitz
marce is a client of my mine my company
hot rod cameras uh he worked a lot on
The Dark Knight he's worked on other
Christopher Nolan movies and uh we've
gotten to hear some great stories uh you
know from from Michael on our podcast
where he he talks about some of the work
that he's done so so yeah we have quite
a few connections but uh but he's
probably the one I would know know most
responsible for the the work except
except for maybe Wally Fister Wally
Fister I've spoken to for hours about
his work with uh with Christopher Nolan
was Oppenheimer your favorite Nolan
film it's a good question no probably
not my favorite I do really like the
prestige but um and I know it's probably
a less popular choice but but uh yeah I
I don't know that might be the prestige
how would you compare and contrast
Christopher Nolan versus David Fincher
their Styles yeah very different styles
um David Fincher is very exacting and
very controlling and uh I know he does a
lot of takes uh I I've spoken with
claudo Miranda uh uh about working with
David Fincher quite a bit and I have
some insights into this process I've met
David Fincher a few times uh in over the
courses of different projects He was
working on back in the era of Benjamin
Button and then also again with gong
girl and we talked about cameras and
Camera technology uh David Fincher uh
has very
very clear goals clear thoughts about
how it is he wants to achieve it and uh
I believe that when David Fincher is
deciding about the the look for a
project he wants collaborators that are
absolutely
in his same sort of mindset about
technology and his same sort of mindset
about what he wants to achieve he
suffers no fools and uh I get the
impression that Christopher Nolan is uh
very much a collaboration and he wants
uh other people to come to the table and
bring what they're good at and to bring
their own uh insights and to try to find
ways to get the absolute best technology
and the best quality out of of the team
so I would say it's it's definitely sort
of maybe a a hard driving versus a more
collaborated collaborative but you know
this is me speaking se you know third
hand I was not there I I have to you get
the information from somebody
else